you're getting a lot of love from people
for your Trump impression are you
enjoying this part of your career is it
all an upside this Trump impression
people will come up to you on the street
you know New York you're walking down
the street yeah and people walk by you
and they're very kind and they're
they're thanking me they're always you
know saying how they think it's great
and they wave to me but but some people
feel compelled to like do their trump
impersonation for me right you know it's
almost like I'm like the number one
gunfighter in town and they're taking me
on it doesn't feel like a challenge to
you when they do it yeah yeah they're
like let's get it on the stuff you know
it's so funny you say that because in
this is a true story when my staff found
out a couple weeks ago that you're gonna
be on the show a lot of people started
coming up to me and they were excited
because they were saying like that's
cool that Alex coming because I do a
Trump impression kidding no and they'd
be like they'd be like and I think mine
is better than the one that he does on
set up live so there's people on your
staff yes if they do a better Trump than
I do
yeah understand they're not even
performers why don't we bring it on
right now why don't we have a Trump
all right well you know they work they
work right backstage I can get him out
of here our first staffer is the show's
production associate she times the show
every day's gonna be Susie's say
tomorrow let's go how are you Susie you
didn't do it I'm doing good thanks for
doing this Susie okay you're gonna go up
against Alec Alec why don't you go first
okay once you get in your Trump here and
then you go first okay Haley Andrew
Jackson been a little later you would
have had a civil war well I was there a
civil war why could that one not have
been worked out okay very good that's
[Applause]
all right Susie go had Andrew Jackson
been a little later there would've been
a civil war why was the Civil War why
could that one not have been worked out
sorry I love you but I think
next next we have our graphic designer
pierre bernard pierre i want you come
out here you think you can take a liqu
you can beat them i'm ready to take them
all okay here we go
Alec why don't you go first we're not
having dessert
and we had the most beautiful piece of
chocolate cake that you've ever seen the
president Jie was enjoying it very good
all right that's a nice one you ready
here we go
what happened dessert and we had the
most beautiful piece of chocolate cake
you've ever seen and president gee
enjoyed it no I it's fine here and
there's something not quite right about
your impression I was like president gia
yeah a presidency but thank you very
much Pierre I appreciate it next we have
our stagehand big Paul let's get big
Paul out here he works
[Applause]
blegh
relax he's the relaxed
Trump Malibu Trump Malibu Trump alright
big Paul do you think you're ready I'm
ready
okay alright so you got me all ready all
right Alec why don't you go ahead do
this yeah yeah tremendous huge fantastic
really fantastic tremendous very nice
Paul you ready give me an bass let's go
tremendous huge fantastic really
fantastic it's a tremendous big ball
that's the closest so far but not quite
it thank you all right thank you very
much whoa all right
finally we have a guy who used to be a
page at NBC now he works for us let's
bring out Jack Jackie here
[Applause]
yeah have we met somewhere monster I
told you never come around me yeah
listen what's not for right now we'll
talk about that writer okay Alec yeah
why don't you go first
someone's doing the raping done I mean
somebody's doing it who's doing the
raping who's doing the raping very nice
I remember that whatever whenever you're
ready go ahead someone's doing the
raping Don I mean somebody's doing it
he's doing the raping who's doing the
raping
fantastic he had you you guys should
spend more time together
[Applause]
you